well brian as vaccination numbers go up
testing numbers are going down but
health officials say testing is still
very important eight news now reporter
victoria saha joining us now live from
the newsroom with some of the reasons
why
victoria many might think just because
more vaccines are being available that
waiting in line to get a covet test
shouldn't be a priority anymore but
health officials say it's the only way
we know where the virus stands
within our community take a look last
month this time more than 7 thousand
tests were administered
yesterday we were right at 4 600 tests
and today
we're learning there was another jump
with more than 8 000 tests
administered over the past day an
important number to keep an
eye on is the test positivity rate which
is going up
nevada's test positivity rate is a
percentage of positive results among all
tests
but you can see it is still way below
what it's been in the past
they use this number to figure out if
there are undiagnosed cases in the
community
the lower the better state health
officials do want
everyone to know the testing is still
key to help stop the spread of the virus
despite vaccinations being available for
all public health measures vaccination
when available
is truly the gold standard of public
health prevention and control
where that's not available again testing
or words available and then the
combination of testing
as well so those are two foundational
parts of the public health response
health officials say even if you are
fully vaccinated and think you might
have been exposed to the virus it's best
to get text
tested more than 1.3 million doses of
the vaccine have been administered in
nevada and health officials say since
they have opened up vaccine eligibility
to those 16 years old and above
the response has been very good
reporting live from the newsroom
victoria saha 8 news now